[Music]
hey what's up guys welcome to winners on
a Wednesday this week not only do I have
someone who's very successful in
property but also someone who is
drop-dead gorgeous please welcome onto
the stone Amanda OH
[Music]
disclaimer we're married yeah so you've
cheated your way to success oh yeah okay
so just tell us the background how long
you've any property well I started out
as a quantity surveyor and so that was
in 2010 actually we're tunable they're
literally not much long after me yeah
yes and so I was obviously mainly
focused on construction yeah and
calculating costs managing costs on
projects and stuff so and ever since
2010 is when I was in property and and
I've always had an interest in property
I used to watch Grand Designs and show
that that yeah so yeah 2010 for me six
years from 2010 to like 2015 I was
working as the quantity surveyor and
then so you that's like a backward
you're not doing property in the same
way like by residential houses don't
want investment after other people's
money yeah so basically what was your
what are you actually doing I was
measuring measuring drawings calculating
how much it was going to cost to build a
building yeah could be school could be
houses and you're a big one for Cola
yeah taking their money yeah and then
basically doing refurb projects
investing their money more them okay
interesting backgrounds now you are
killing it in poverty so not only you do
very well on the investment side but you
do know a lot from scratch yourself so
you set up you've set up and I hate you
my management company you don't refer
quite big refurb projects for people
you've been really successful but why
don't we just rewind a little bit to
when we first got together because I
know people always ask people always ask
you
was asked me how we met I didn't date
how does it kind of happen because we
didn't come together through business
did we know everyone always I think
thinks that that's how we met but we
actually met in a social setting a
wedding a wedding and I remember
noticing you in the church because you
were loud you were singing loudly I
looked back and I just thought I was
that guy but then you came to the
reception in the evening and you ended
up stuck next to me at our table
so we met we tried we fell in love you
didn't know about my property business I
wasn't so my brand I wasn't so big
online I would just quietly building my
portfolio and had a really large
property portfolio at that time but I
didn't tell you until you didn't tell me
until before you proposed did you feel
cheated because I remember did you feel
that lied to me cuz I remember I didn't
want to tear up a property business
because we were just getting to know
each other as people where they went way
so I was knowing you you were no maid I
just thought I don't want to go on about
my business I just want to just get to
know you I didn't feel cheated no but
I'm not the only person that takes
things to heart anyway I think school is
like easily offended yeah sir I just
thought I just thought mommy mentioned
that would you member I told you yes sir
and I told okay you said what would you
say if I told you that I had a million
pounds worth of debt and I was just
thinking oh and I remember what you said
that's all I said that to you yeah I
remember saying that to you because it
which is totally true because I had a
lot of mortgages so I'm thinking well
I'm not going to tell you about all the
assets and all the well yeah I would
just say what would you say if I told
you everybody knows with the deck and
you a lot Oh dad remember you said oh
wow I mean you want me to get some
overtime what's your plan and at that
point I thought we're not married we
really love we've been together a little
while but not long enough for me to have
to tell you and then when you said that
I just thought yes she is the one you
bring yourself and then I told you the
folks
till when she just met was good then you
know really like Lars I like because
ultimately you know you're not like a
super materialistic person are you and
you love property yeah so I told you and
then we got married but you didn't want
to quit your job as a conscience event I
really didn't learn because I started my
ABC absolute process of becoming a
chartered surveyor yeah and that was
just like after all the things that I've
done that was just the next step
naturally thing is most people are going
to property they they were only going to
college because they hate their job and
they're like I hate my job on the scale
yeah that wasn't actually because I did
enjoy my ideas even to the point of
marrying a millionaire you still were
like I want to do my job man yeah and I
am carried on until we've been on our
honeymoon and then we did a mission trip
to Zambia and then you were like oh
should we go to America next and I was
like I've never been to America yeah
thinking oh my goodness I want to get to
make my boys dream again tonight that
that want anything all we did is left
and I was like oh and you just like okay
well I'm I'll just go on ahead then
shall I and and at that point I thought
oh my gosh I mean as much as I love my
job
yeah I'll only literally always have 26
days holiday a year
yeah and I'll never ever have you know
have the freedom to do what I want when
I want
yeah and so at that point lassen are
just like okay I'm gonna quit my job
yeah I did that so you look at your job
but you quit it because you wanted the
freedom to be able to work on your terms
yeah and you were like do really well
would you career as a surveyor
so when you quit your job you didn't
want to just kind of help me on the
property so yeah I really wanted to get
my teeth into it inter actually learn
and yeah
you know the different things sir and
obviously and your a lot about
construction and refurbishment that but
I didn't really know things in terms of
managing tenants and you know just like
that sort of stuff so I thought oh you
know I need to learn so I'm set up a
management company managing HMOs it's
mainly HMOs and then also a company that
was carrying out refurb so I'm utilizing
my skills from my job looking at you
know getting builders to come out and
looking at the quotes making sure that
they weren't charging too much so sort
of using I got the best of both feelings
I was still doing a little bit of what I
was doing before but you know for myself
right yeah the thing is most most
businesses
I think 80% of businesses fire in the
first five years but you started that
business a few off your back
really and it wasn't yeah we won't do it
together you would do that off your own
back and it's a really successful
company yeah and you're making good
money yeah we're making good money and
you teamed up you got you got a few
people on the case you employed max yeah
and then what happened and then um I got
pregnant with our first child and and at
that point I was kind of think you know
you know I was enjoying it but then I
was thinking or on to the next season
yeah I want to be a moment to fully
embrace that um and you know thankfully
I'm in the position where I can stay at
home and you don't have to go to work so
I decided then that I was just gonna be
full-time stay-at-home mom yeah and
that's why yeah we've got someone ahead
of what I was doing and then I left that
was that full time when we were after
that so you had the all the experience
of a background of building yeah but
then residential property and tenants
and management and HMOs but on top of
that the experience to set up a business
which is very different you almost
transition someone from an employee to
not a millionaire's wife but an employee
to an entrepreneur in your own right
yeah cool yeah it was really interesting
actually because growing up it was all
I've known
told us okay you go to school getting
the best to get a job basically working
a job until yeah so it was them you know
going out of my comfort zone but you
know you're always saying if you're not
growing you're dying and it was one of
those things where I thought you know
it's really comfortable to be in a job
and to never step out but moving from
being an employee to an entrepreneur it
was them it was a big move but something
that I think has had a really good
positive effect on myself because as a
person I've grown and I learn more so as
I've never changed that I think it was a
what would you say to people that say
like oh yeah it's alright for you
because the business didn't have to work
because you know you can come back to
you nice house and and and you
comfortable situation what would you say
to those guys I'd say that well if
you're not willing to try you'll never
know and the only way the only way
you're ever going to succeed really is
by taking a chance and yeah I mean I was
coming home and you know either way I
was gonna be fine but I mean if you
don't take the chance you'll never know
yeah so you saying that is only saying
saying a lot about yourself and you know
your self-doubt yeah and you know your
lack of confidence in yourself yeah
anyone I think anyone that ever says
until right for you because it's like
okay
this is my life this is like you were
born in Britain Africa yeah in in Harare
you know like anyone that says this one
work for you really say more about them
definitely did you just gotta take the
concert you doubt that yeah exactly
you know and you can you can do mean you
can turn anything into you can take
something and be like oh we gotta be the
victim oh yeah yeah but you don't have
to be like that yeah so had a couple
kids which is amazing and you know what
noni you were fabulous wife but you're a
great mom yeah but honestly because I
know when we got married you know I was
really busy doing the property stuff
buying houses taking a lots of staff I
was also doing training events and I
remember having a conversation with you
say look now I'm married I don't have a
mom I lost thinking I don't have to work
I could remember more on a honeymoon and
we calculated
island-hopping owner own Greece and we
calculated that just off of half of the
passive income that we began from the
property portfolio we could stay in the
Greek island hopping around to rob them
of stuff forever
like we'd got to a point where I've got
I've got the business to a point before
we do not married where me year the kids
that we didn't have them but we would
never have to work but I think you
sensed in me that it was more about just
the money it was more about mission and
just because you don't have to work I
mean how boring it would it be just
lying on a beach even when we had it
Ruby when ruby was born I took a
performance opportunity and Howells on
you like Davina you want to do some I
have so much testosterone in me and
energy just desperately now I'm going in
a cage doing a cage would just let off
some energy yeah you know earthy the
fact that you saw will and said because
I said to you I don't know if I'm gonna
carry on with the training I'll probably
it's gonna you're right no you gotta do
it I should mention yeah and you really
released me and cheer me on to do that
and in the same way you know now I'm
doing that for you in your own business
and in what you're doing so tell us some
of the projects that you work too late
you know just yesterday you're in
Doncaster
yeah just yesterday I went to Doncaster
collected some coffee I mean you say we
okay we obviously we're one yeah we're
like one person but we do have our roles
and our own properties and our own
things
we share em only but then we also have
different pots so so it's going to
people to say but this is a lot of these
property doesn't you're doing I know
we've got we've got look with Langley
Park the building houses we've got
property the HMOs in Birmingham we've
got a pile of property but Doncaster
that just completed tonight which you're
gonna do what with the apartments slice
and dice and and all this stuff is stuff
that you've learned yourself your
experience then you're heading up so
talking about education because I know
that you remember when after we've got
you said I'd be midea not to go on the
training programs something that I
realized what to myself was just that
you know I've got so many resources
around me I mean I like to you yeah
biggest property training you know so
much and I just thought what a shame it
would be to just sort of you know stay
at home be lazy dumb myself down I
didn't get myself down and I just
thought you know you do all these
training units that I've seen changing
people's lives um I thought you know I
really want to apply myself and you know
learn more I'm so been to the training I
also picked a lot from you talking to
you and stuff and I just thought I
really wanted to take that information
utilize it and actually just go and do
it myself that's correct
yeah and you're a big believer in
investing in yourself yeah you've also
recently just got back from Spain Spain
I was and taking part in a in a program
by Tihar Becca
and you know things like that I've you
know something that you've encouraged me
and a lot actually self development of
self growth something that never really
even really thought about myself I was
just kind of in my mode my blinkers on
career you kind of do those things right
and this is saying by Jim Rohn that says
what is it self self no formal education
makes you a living for self education
thanks for fortune yeah and I feel like
you know you can be rich you know
financially but you can also be rich in
yourself yeah so um so yeah so I think
self investment is you know number one
was the most important like you say and
then obviously with the poverty stuff I
feel like it's really you know I'm able
to help people you know those of stuff
but doing the charity stuff yeah I think
having that enable us to to do that you
know our former Zimbabwe I know how
people struggle in Africa and being able
to go back in and make a difference you
know with the education
that's amazing how did you bill the time
being a not full-time one but being a
mom wife homemaker entrepreneur a
business person going out doing programs
to kids like how do you manage your life
well delegating yeah having someone to
look after the kids
no I'm not people when people think now
and I think you just let someone just
bring up your kids oh yeah we call her
aunty right so just someone that just
helps with general but tasks yes the
door stop the other boring stuff that
you know take me out the game I do
laundry things like that I think you
know being able to delegate and then
actually spend quality time with the
kids to bed yeah having someone in look
after them when I go out you know cuz
I'll say to you you know like oh I'll
set up everyone's got different sets of
this I'm responsible ultimately for the
business your response not ultimately
for the home but that doesn't mean that
what I have to do the business and you
have to do the home
it just means responsible you outsource
everything you do more property stuff
than I do these days you're out
negotiating wheelin dealin the biggest
thing go show to go it you know so
what's the next plan to be there what
are the big things that you want to
achieve are the next problems well I
want to do lots more you really excited
about house building yes I am house
building I think that will be the the
biggest achievement in the next problems
you know I when I was a quantity
surveyor I worked on a project where the
council were building houses yeah
and now actually being in the position
where you know it's not someone else's
weight and yeah I'm actually doing it
from the ground up I think that's really
exciting about you might know as well in
the property in the property space is a
lot of people like to just buy you know
even buy low rent high the idea of
buying a cheap house renting a maximum
return you're not really interested in
that Scimitar are you kind of like to
create homes restore buildings yeah
build houses like create homes so what
why is that I don't know I've always
been interested in architecture and I
don't know I just think when you go
back back to the boat or to the
structure of the property I just find
that interesting I think it's a it just
excites ya bit more you know and I guess
when people say all greedy landlords you
know buying all the houses it's like no
no what you're doing is you're taking
properties that are ugly and then
turning them into viewable homes almost
the solving part of the housing crisis
yeah biggest lesson that you've learned
in the last five years please like share
I know the biggest lesson that I've
learned is that if you don't take action
yeah you'll just you'll never ever know
what you know what is what more is there
for you yeah so I think you can spend a
lot of time just thinking oh I wish I
could do that you know but I think being
outrageous and you know just taking
action is no matter how silly something
sounds yeah you know just just thinking
thinking it and then actually doing it
so you can think a lot but doing it and
I think that makes all the difference
yeah just do it yeah so if I did not you
know if I'd have just thought wouldn't
know but I'm comfortable being in my job
and you know oh never mind about the
holidays you know I could I would have
never you know go to the person that I
am now yeah
so I I just think taking action is the
most important thing like what was it
like the first time he came to the
property investors crash course I was I
was nervous actually because and it was
weak because I was nervous about having
to call and like you know make the make
the boot making points because all the
projects have to do stuff yeah that was
my biggest because it was like what do I
have to I'm very good at learning I mean
you know I'm very good at just like all
taking notes reading and you know so
that was different because it's cool and
unique
you don't actually learn how to do just
a reticle theoretical stuff so actually
picking up the phone making vocal you
know doing taking action and doing that
was the thing that was the most
nerve-wracking but when I did it I was
actually it was exciting it I felt
empowered after it yeah I left and I
honestly felt like I can do this what
will be your biggest have lost someone
watching this what are the next steps
next steps let's say get booked on to
the crash course because it will change
your life
honestly : you're awesome thank you
hope you found that useful guys I'm
Samuel that was Amanda
and we really sincerely hope to help you
in your property journey so get yourself
down to an event subscribe like share
and book onto the property investors
crash course see you real soon